this podcast has bad words
hello patrons it's time we're here to
talk about the coronavirus we're here
with tk coleman you can find him at tk
coleman.com this is a patreon only
episode usually we put it behind
our paywall for the folks who really
support us there on
patreon we dive deep during these
maximal episodes we're going to dive
deep today
talking about the coronavirus talking
about pandemics talking about crises
but because we feel like this is a
public service announcement we want to
put this in the main feed as well
before we do that i just want to say
thank you for being a patreon supporter
if you are a patreon
supporter uh your two dollars goes much
farther than you realize
uh you are paying for sean and all his
kids
and jordan he probably has kids he that
he doesn't know about
but also jess and and her family and of
course us
and allows us to pay for the studio
space all the equipment and because we
keep our podcast 100 advertisement free
yet we think advertisements suck
and they are a big part of the problem
we don't want to be part of the problem
we don't want to be part of the
noise and we don't want to talk about
mattresses
or or postage and so
is that what the is that the in vogue
thing to advertise now postage
yeah yeah in fact uh we were talking
about mark maron's new special called
end times fun and
he makes fun of uh what rogan advertises
oh yeah
and then he makes fun of what he
advertises himself he goes i'm more of a
stamps.com
kind of guy myself and um yeah we don't
do advertisements thank you for your
support it really does
go a long way if you're not a supporter
and you want to support us especially
during these trying times
you can do so at the minimalists.com
support
you can become a regular supporter you
get a
maximal episode every single week it's a
longer much more personal
uh much deeper dive every week and
it's a totally separate endeavor from
the regular podcast that's part of our
the minimalist private podcast so what
you're listening to right now
is the minimalist private podcast and tk
i wanted to start with this article we
have this little
on the maximum episodes we do something
called more about less
we we use an article of sort of a there
he just coughed again i didn't cough
did you see it put a mask on i did not
cough i cleared my throat i'm not i'm
not paranoid
but i'm leaving and so we use an article
as a jump off point to just
to discuss some things in this article
my doctor sent to me yesterday
and it's sort of this aggregate we'll
put a link to it in the show notes it's
on a blog called the slate
star codex and this guy writes a blog
here that um well it's covering
ever this particular blog post is called
coronavirus lynx
speculation open thread and it has these
different topics the first topic is
prepping and he says for a description
of why you might want to prep
see this blog post here for description
of
how to prep see this article by kelsey
here
for a really intense guide by
professional prepper
c here but there's such a thing as
being too intense and so people often
ask
us about like well what about preppers
or how much should i have prepared
during
the minimal episode ryan we you were
talking about just in case versus
just for win we have these two rules and
the minimalist rule book uh it's so
important to be able to decipher between
the two
and because we can justify anything just
so
and that's what's causing this panic
right now people are going to
target or walmart or wherever i need
this just the case because i see
everyone else doing it yeah and that mob
mentality
is causing everyone to panic it is
create has created its own sort of
metaphorical
zombie apocalypse because we are now the
zombies were behaving like zombies
and that's what we talked about and and
this uh this guy who's running this blog
here says but there's
uh such a thing as being too intense you
probably won't need to store
water the water kept running in wuhan
you probably won't need a generator the
wuhan has electricity so what he's
talking about here is the epicenter of
this crisis
where more people are affected and
infected
than anywhere else in the entire world
they still have running water they still
have electricity
so the most important thing seems to be
food and toiletries and other
necessities
uh if the epidemic gets bad you'll want
food so you can avoid going out to
coronavirus-filled supermarkets and
restaurants yeah so it's funny with the
food with the food thing it's not about
uh the grocery stores are going to run
out of food
it's being able to self quarantine you
want to have enough food for you and
your family
to be able to self quarantine as long
not as long as you can but you know for
for a week at a time at least yeah and
that's the recommendation that
i know sam harris makes and it's a
recommendation that i make as well
it's uh by the way if you want to a link
to the
a bunch of different coronavirus
important articles and podcasts go to
the coronavirus post that
the minimalist put up called let's talk
about the coronavirus just the
minimalists.com coronavirus
you can find it over there there's a
bunch of links in that article that will
take you to
reasonable sources uh that have a
measured nuanced view
about this and then of course the the
blog post we're referencing right now
has a bunch of resources in it
and as well if the epidemic gets bad you
want food so for me i have uh
i have five cases of sardines because
ultimately that that's all that i mean
i can survive off sardines my family can
survive off sardines
for many weeks if we needed to and
here's the thing too josh
you actually eat sardines on a regular
basis yes you didn't just buy canned
sardines no i eat sardines most days
right exactly where i like i was you
know trader joe's and i see people
buying cases of tuna fish
and you know damn well like they're not
eating tuna fish every single day
but because of this hoarding mentality
they're yeah so uh yeah just pointing
out how
you actually bought something that you
do eat right that's something somebody
told you
right exactly no i i usually buy one
case at a time i just have
four about four extras now yeah but i'm
still gonna eat those right
uh put a link to the wild planet at
sardines because i i mean
i don't think they'll sell out but they
might um and so folks if they're
interested
i just get them from amazon and we're
actually gonna talk about amazon here in
a moment
so um and if you get the coronavirus and
are feeling sick you'll want food at
home so you don't have to go
too far out of bed right if you get the
coronavirus you do want to have some
food at home so having at least a week's
worth of food
is important going beyond a week it
starts to get a bit sketchy right
uh and so i have enough sardines will
probably last several weeks at this
point yeah but i don't have
you know freezer freezers deep freezers
full of stuff
because that level of preparation is too
intense for me and i'm not i'm
personally not comfortable with it and i
also know
that even in the epicenter of the
pandemic
you don't have these sorts of problems
so we're preparing for problems that
don't exist
isn't isn't that a fair way to put it
yeah there's a very uh useful economic
distinction that comes into play here
so it's transaction cost versus
opportunity cost transaction cost is the
tag price cost it's the direct amount
that you pay
in order to buy a service or good you
know i'm i pay twelve dollars for a
movie ticket five dollars for the
popcorn
opportunity cost is the value of the
best opportunity that you have to forego
or sacrifice
in order to pay for some good or service
and usually when we think about
situations like this we only think in
terms of transaction costs well
it's only going to cost me five dollars
to buy that extra can of tuna or
only gonna cost me you know five dollars
to buy that extra thing and that's all i
gotta pay
but there's an opportunity cost there as
well and that means you are losing out
on the opportunities that come
from saving for something that is a real
need
so if you overestimate how much you need
and you get too intense
and you buy food for two weeks three
weeks that's gonna really hurt you
if you get to week three you don't need
that food you have all this extra stuff
that you don't need
and what if a real medical emergency
happens well you've already spent your
money on that
savings is not just like this moral
virtue
it's actually a decision to capitalize
on future opportunities and emergencies
don't compromise that ability by
over investing in just in case needs
yeah he goes on to say here
that uh what about amazon getting fresh
groceries delivered whenever you want
seems like a pretty good alternative to
stocking up on canned beans right
you but you need faith that it won't be
so bad that
amazon's logistics break down and
i think that faith is mostly justified
because the chinese version of amazon
seems to be
still be making deliveries in wuhan
right now
and it's hard to imagine given a
pandemic
nuclear war or demon apocalypse getting
anything getting between jeff bezos and
his next billion dollars
three cheers for capitalism i mean this
is one of those things
and we talk about the market and in
being an advocate for the free market
but tk is this one of those examples
where the free market
a place like amazon or any of these
other places the step even local
business especially local businesses
that step up to help i give an example
belcampo
who ryan and i are big fans of as a
local restaurant you've been to bel
campo with us i think
before uh yeah they got like one of the
best hamburgers
yeah and so they have a farm here in
california so it's all
sustainably raised uh meat and
what they what they're doing right now
is free deliveries to anyone
in in la county from their app free
deliveries of
food that you can prepare on your own or
their own prepared food
the meals instead of having to go to
their restaurant so local businesses
step
up as well you want to talk a little bit
about that wait what do you want me to
say well
that's not how the free market is
actually giving us opportunity and
giving us access to things that
we feel like we're not going to have
access to yeah i mean
the the very fact that there are
multiple businesses like that that
are capable of delivering goods and
services
is itself the product of self-interested
innovation
it's not the result of someone putting a
gun to someone else's head and saying
you must serve humanity it's the result
of people trying to figure out creative
ways that they can provide for
themselves and their family
and in order to survive in business what
do you have to do you got to figure out
how to solve problems for people
that are valuable enough for them to pay
you so the free market has put us in
this kind of position
where we are able to deliver like this
even you talking about amazon
uh being able to rely on something like
that
how people in china have had to have
faith in that and it's been able to help
them out
that's the result of free market
innovation so it can be easy during
times like this
to find that total jerk that's hogging
up a bunch of stuff they don't need and
trying to charge
seventy dollars for hand sanitizer or
something along those lines
but the free market is solving a lot
more problems than it creates and
it also punishes those jerks because a
lot of those people are left stuck with
inventory that they can't move
yeah and we're gonna talk about that
next week on the economy podcast as well
he goes on to say coronavirus can remain
on objects for a few days and amazon
warehouse workers
may come into work with the condition so
if you're using amazon as part of your
self quarantine strategy
you should probably open packages away
from your main living space
using gloves and discs and then
disinfect anything
inside that doesn't have its own
packaging from the manufacturer and
that's something
important to think about if you are
still getting packages right now
remember you could have the coronavirus
or just the flu virus on it too yeah but
you could certainly have the coronavirus
there
next section here is how bad will it be
from the chinese numbers
people have estimated these death rates
and really what it looks like here what
we're seeing
this is the the mortality rate if you're
older than 80 years old
it's 22 death rate so it's really really
high
if you're ella's age my daughter it's
zero it's
no one under 10 has died from this and
so they but
you have to keep in mind the reason
they're closing these schools is because
these kids
are now coming home and they're passing
on to grandparents right who are 80 and
1 in 5 chance of dying and so that's why
this is so
dire for many of us not because i mean
ryan is crazy healthy what he'll do is
like
he'll get a slight sore throat and then
it'll go away
but if he was living with his grandma
she would be the one at risk but
him running into seven other people who
might live with their grandma
they that's how this whole thing spreads
yeah and that's why it's out of control
we're beyond containment at this point
oh right yeah
it's just a matter of time and so we
hear this term flattening the curve
right and so the reason we want to
flatten the curve we want to
because somewhere between 30 to 70
percent of all
adults are going to become affected with
this before it come becomes endemic
and and so in that process
as these people are infected we don't
want this huge spike right now we don't
want
70 american population be infected today
our health care system couldn't handle
it
exactly but if 70 of the population is
infected over the course of 18 months
then poss it's still a strain on the
health care system much more but it
doesn't collapse
exactly yeah and so that's really what
they're talking about here there's a
chart with age distribution and
hospitalization i'm not going to go
through all the stats
but you can you can check that out here
uh self-quarantining now versus later
now saves more lives is is the main key
that he makes in in the article here uh
what is the end game
some sources argue that recovered
patients can get re-infected with
coronavirus i.e people don't build
immunity after surviving at once
oh wow and i didn't realize that but
they don't know if it's true it's an
argument it's one
hypothesis right so let's be clear
everything we're bringing forward here
is the best information we have based on
on scientific facts
however there's still a whole lot of
speculation yeah there's so there's so
many unknowns even like the
how long it survives on surfaces like
they still don't know that 100
i've seen like less than 24 hours and
i've seen up to
72 hours and it's like it also depends
on the surface right so if it's on
copper it'll it'll die relatively
quickly because
uh uh it'll react with copper viruses in
general react with copper copper helps
kill
viruses if it's on metal like stainless
steel it can last much much longer but
how long we
we don't know that's why it is important
for us to to constantly wash our hands
and to avoid touching our faces and
that's hard advice
yeah and i i still fail at it every day
but i am touching myself
i'm touching myself i mean less and less
as a result of the i am masturbating
like crazy during this
but i've washed my hands
the average person touches their face
like you know 55 times a day or
something crazy
yeah i mean my face is itching right now
just talking about it to be fair i've
been touching becca's face a lot more
but before you touch him you're doing
your part yeah
whatever you guys are into this is what
you get on these maximal episodes
masturbation jokes mostly just yeah
exactly all right uh so
yeah yeah let's see um there's a
microbiologist here um
healthcare home healthcare some people
in
the rationalist community have put
together a document with some useful
suggestions among them
most coronavirus infections will be
generally mild and probably treated at
home
we talked about uh mattiavella may or
may not have the coronavirus we suspect
it's just a cold or flu
and that's what we're hoping for we
couldn't find tests so we don't we can't
know for sure but
he has mild symptoms right now um and
the problem is we can't
test we're doing a terrible job as the
united states
our government is doing a horrible job
the cdc
the fda and the current administration
no didn't you hear our government
absolve themselves of responsibility
yes but then you have uh supposed third
world countries
like senegal who are doing a phenomenal
job and even coming up with new tests
that might change the entire world
you also have countries uh specifically
south korea
who are doing drive-through testing now
and we're going to see some amazing
outcomes from there's going to be this
this disparity in outcomes between
places like south korea
and the united states because we did not
respond quickly we did not respond
appropriately
and by the way uh the the way that we're
set up right now
is we don't have other countries who
even want to help us at this point
right because we haven't done a good job
of being inclusive no we've done a good
job of like ignoring everything up until
the last minute and isolating ourselves
in a way
that is not productive and so i think if
uh
even if we had screwed this up but we
had done a good job uh
if our country had done a good job of
partnering with other countries
you might have countries like south
korea who would be a lot more willing
to to come over and try to help us out
or senegal willing to come over here and
help us out
and it's much more difficult right now
yeah tk you look how you want to say
something
man i i i i just kind of cringe when we
say if we had done if we had done if our
country
um because i don't think that's you me
and ryan no i think our government
and and i think maybe when we get into
our discussion um
you'll see exactly why that's a very
important distinction to make
it so i i do think it is possible and
i and i think it's actually the case for
our experience
that our government can make decisions
that put us in very compromised
positions
and they are decisions that we ourselves
would not necessarily make
they are decisions that we ourselves can
protest and can say are
irrational and i think if it's fair to
criticize the free market and say hey
here's an inefficiency in the market
what are we going to do about that i
think it's equally fair to
point out government inefficiencies
government incompetence
that put us in these kinds of positions
because i do not think we are in this
healthcare position because of the lack
of innovation
but because of artificial restrictions
that are being placed on our ability to
innovate
by our government itself i hear i think
this whole epidemic we're experiencing
is one of the best arguments for free
markets we can possibly make
and i'll save a lot of this for you know
when we get into it but but i think the
healthcare system
might be one of the best examples we
have of the real kind of price gouging
that we don't talk about because it's a
socially acceptable form of it
i hear you tk you're blaming obama
thanks oh biden thanks
loud and clear tk um
but it's not ridiculous though like oh
my god anyway
so i hear you tk you're just racist
basically you're racist
so i'd say your race full
all right all right so so bring us back
on the rails here josh
i will i'll do my best when we're
talking about
the the free market versus the the
government here
let me give you one example of of total
ineptitude
the fda and the cdc
have a sen actually let me see if it's
in this article cdc
um cdc oh basically the fda and ctcs
conspired against us
yeah here we go no this is perfect no
problem so bad
over regulation can't make it worse this
is yeah this is just to to
to put a say that again there's no
problem so bad that overregulation can't
make it worse
okay yes and i would i would even say
something more conservative
i would say there is no problem so bad
that
some form of modest regulation can't
make
horrifically worse oh boy well uh let's
at least start with
because it's not the amount of
regulation it's not the quality of it
it's the quantity of it
just the little amount of regulation in
the wrong direction can create great
tragedy yeah yeah well we can definitely
i think we'll disagree on that
and and we can unpack it eventually
hopefully yeah but we can all agree that
over-regulation's a bad thing yes
right yeah and so so this is what the
the blog post here says so far the
government
has bungled its coronavirus response
pretty egregiously
most hospitals have the equipment
in-house to detect
the coronavirus but the fda
banned them from using it they said all
coronavirus tests
needed fda approval and refused
to approve anything except the official
test
made by the cdc unfortunately the
official cdc test
was defective the test itself worked
but one component in the test kit was
broken
most hospitals had their own supply of
this component
and could have substituted it in but the
way the fda approved the cdc test
banned them from doing this good god
this is
this is extreme this isn't just
incompetence
this almost feels like they were trying
to not have people get tested which
why wouldn't they want people tested tk
yeah we'll see i i i i
share the belief of those who say never
settle
for conspiracy when incompetence is a
perfectly right i'm not saying it's a
conspiracy i'm saying it's right out in
the open
right i mean because our president said
hey that might make our numbers look bad
yeah yeah let's go back to why it's not
a conspiracy it's coming out of his own
lips
yeah well well but but but i think even
prior to this president
like these kinds of restrictions on on
how we evaluate
what sorts of uh medicinal innovations
are allowed into the marketplace
they've existed for a very long time
you're right these aren't his these are
president trump's restrictions
right right they've existed long before
trump and long before obama if you want
to go there too this didn't like
this didn't start with like whatever
president you arbitrate
hold hold on there was a lot of changing
of
uh and dismantling of certain parts of
the cdc
under under this regulation and i'm not
one to sit here and be like
you know thanks obama or it's all
trump's fault you mean administration
under this administration yeah
administration what did i say regulation
oh yes yeah under the administration so
so it's like uh
there are certain aspects of it where
yes it has actually changed i mean there
was a
there was a response uh an epidemic
response
team that under the cdc yeah under the
cdc that has been
cut in half under this administration
removed dismantled totally dismantled
oh wow they're gone so i take that back
it's been totally dismantled so
um there is a little bit to blame of how
it's changed in the last just few years
of of how we're responding
but but to your point though yeah there
are certainly systems in place that have
been
and i don't want to like derail what you
were trying to say tk but it is
i think it is important because again i
don't want to sit here and be like
thanks obama and it's all trump's fault
but i do but the more i dig the more i
realize like yes there's a problem with
the way the administration is going
right now
that is preventing us from from having
the exact
care and help that we need as a as a
society tk can we agree on this there
are some countries who are handling this
better than the united states
absolutely yeah and so so there are
there are governments
that are doing a better job than our
current government and our so
and our government could do a better job
than what they are currently doing
yeah and that's not that's not a
partisan thing and
and and there there are mafias that are
less violent than other mafias
[Laughter]
there are murderers that kill fewer
people than other murderers okay let's
expand it let's keep going with this
yeah
yeah what i'm saying is like
far be it from me to ever use any
resources that i will ever have to come
to the defense of politicians or
politics
that like like if i died right now um
i i feel like there are plenty of people
who will use their resources and gifts
for that
that's what i'm not i'm not on this
planet for i'm not on this planet for
that
i'm here to point people back to their
own personal power and to try to fight
against the things whether it's
political or anything else that get in
the way of us
embracing and expressing our own
personal power i'm not a political guy
i'm decisively apolitical okay
and i think undue faith in politics and
politicians
this whole philosophy of oh we just got
to get the right person in office
i think that is one of the greatest
problems in our society
that keeps us from taking individual
responsibility from our for our world
we get too comfortable with saying well
i showed up to the boating booth
and i made my decisions and i voted for
my guy
so this is your president not my
president i can't do anything else
so i'm just going to complain for the
next four years until hopefully i can
win
i think that's lazy i think that's
reckless i think that's irresponsible
and if you really care about the world
you will exercise your ability to vote
in the free market
365 days out of the year you really care
about society get out there and do
things
not when it's politically hot to do them
get out there and take charge of your
life economically
take charge of your life financially
take charge of your life in terms of
health
take take responsibility for your
relationships in your neighborhood so
i get annoyed by the talk of politics
because i think most of it is a form of
socially acceptable self-righteous
excuse-making
by people who want to put the
responsibility for the world on
those who have power and it's based on
the presupposition that you and i don't
have power
i i totally agree with what you're
saying man but here's the thing though
i'm not saying it doesn't have an effect
okay but is it okay but for
me it's the starting point i think
politics is the lagging indicator
of change that takes place on a personal
level sure politicians will follow us
they will do whatever is politically
profitable to do
don't think that things like marijuana
are
more legal now because politicians
experience some kind of spiritual
enlightenment
don't think that you know like after
rosa parks refused to give up her seat
that the world and the politicians just
became more enlightened right that's not
what happened
politicians experienced the change
as something that was more politically
profitable and they said oh we can't be
taken seriously anymore in our careers
unless we give the people what they
refuse to live without
so when we demand freedom they respect
our freedom and they step back
but when we show that we can be easily
duped with promises of free goodies
and other fantasies that they themselves
prove over and over again that they
cannot deliver
then they'll keep giving us that you
know so politician politics is just not
the starting point for personal change
i don't dismiss it as irrelevant i don't
condemn you if you worry about certain
things
but that's never where change begins but
however politicians i'll tell you what i
will give them credit for
i'll tell you what their genius is at
they are geniuses at
centering themselves in the middle of
movements that ordinary human beings
have initiated
and put and positioning themselves as
the poster boy
you know for that movement taking the
credit you know um
you know but but but i think the credit
belongs to us that's all um and
and i know there was something different
from that you wanted me to talk about
but i just got like so angry
and so fired up that i had to just no
this is going to talk about what i hear
you saying is is that the
government is a murderer and it doesn't
matter who the administration is
is that yes some governments are going
to murder less than other governments i
totally
understand that but right now this
situation today
with the coronavirus testing there is
there is a problem
and this goes back to what josh was
talking about with the regulation how it
has
stopped us from getting what we need
because of very
specific regulations done under uh un
under this administration
i'm not trying to blame i'm not sitting
here saying oh it's trump's fault i'm
just saying that uh
just to the point of this article that
there is uh there is regulation
that has happened today uh that has
totally stunted us
from really knowing how many people have
the coronal virus
these aren't these aren't trump
administration regulations these are old
regulations
and what what tk is saying oh i didn't
realize that so yes
you're saying that these are all fda and
cdc regulations okay okay okay
so the so the cd and by the way
libertarians
and anarchists have been complaining for
years no one listens to them
they've been complaining for years about
the
lack of innovation in medicine and
health care precisely because of this
interesting so the cd and plenty of
presidents on both sides have had the
opportunity to do something about it
and have ignored it because it wasn't
politically profitable for them
i thought you were saying this i thought
you were saying the cdc just
just outlawed the using of the tests
these these are current regulations okay
so i'll keep going here in the article
here fda approved we opened that door
uh fda approved the cdc test banned them
from doing this the cdc tried as hard as
it could to fix their broken test
quickly
but they weren't able to do it fast
enough to satisfy demand
in order to ration the scarce tests
during the minimal episode
that we did about panda pandemic
preparation i talked about how
matt diabello couldn't get a test and i
have five really well connected doctors
and none of them could get him a test
and so it's because of this because of
these these regulations here right
and so they couldn't do it uh fast
enough in order to to ration the scarce
test
they mandated that hospitals only test
people
who had recently been to china or been
in close contact with someone who had
and there's another there's an example
here this was a disaster for example
here's a story there's a link to a
person who traveled to japan
where the coronavirus is active he came
back to the united states
starting to develop symptoms and went to
a hospital the hospital said
since he hadn't been to china they
couldn't test him
and sent him home even though he had the
symptoms
of the coronavirus because of these
regulations saying you can't test that
person right wow
yeah but even worse regulations have
been intact for
for decades yeah i don't know how long
but at least a decade probably multiple
decades i just think it's weird how
what regulation what regulation is in
place
the verbiage that says only people who
have visited china can get tested
like that that's what i don't understand
how is that specific regulation been in
place no
no that was that was an additional
regulation that the hospital made
and the cdc probably i don't know for
sure to filter out like
because they only had you know if they
only have 75 tests who
who can we give these tests to right we
can't give it to everyone
because of these decades-old regulations
from the fda and the cdc
to make things even worse the policy
ruled out
by fiat ever being able to detect when
the epidemic spread to the
united states so in mid-february when a
patient with no history
of travel to china came to a hospital in
california
with coronavirus symptoms the doctors
had to ask the cdc
for special permission to test the cdc
dithered for four days before granting
the permission during which nobody put
any work into containing the disease
finally the test came back
positive after after some health workers
had already been infected now health
workers that
become infected with this they are
working with
elderly patients they as doctors know
and admit i read an article on it this
morning
they admit that they may might
accidentally
kill people and these doctors aren't
even allowed to get tested because they
don't meet the requirements
but let's talk about the guy that's
buying too much toilet paper
because that's more socially acceptable
right right like i can't really make too
many enemies talking about that guy
right right yeah right hard to criticize
power
though it's hard to criticize the
socially acceptable heroes
it's easy to talk about price gouging
when it's some you know uh
complete dork that we can all agree on
yeah it's a lot harder to talk about
price gouging when it's our
beloved politicians really hard and
that's the weird thing
we have beloved politicians who are also
the most hated people as well
by almost by by definition like in order
to be
to be loved you have to be hated and it
calls us in a weird way it calls us the
love right
and this is the difference because i you
know with tribalism tribalism unites
against something community
unites around something and and politics
has become especially in the
few most recent decades it has become
tribalism where
we're uniting against those those
libtards or we're
we're uniting against those kooky
conservatives or whatever
as opposed to being a community that
says oh actually we have these shared
values why don't
why don't we look at what our values are
because my values are apolitical we had
p buddha judge on this podcast
and we didn't talk to him about politics
we talked to him about values
because that's something that's
important to me if we are going to have
some sort of leadership i want
leadership
that that talks about values i don't
care whether you're
blue or red d or r that that doesn't
matter as much to me
as being able to articulate what your
values are because your beliefs might be
different
from my beliefs yeah but that doesn't in
fact ryan's beliefs are radically
different from mine
sean and i have different beliefs tk you
and i have different beliefs
and but we tend to have similar values
and we can unite around something
as a because if we're uniting against
something as soon as that enemy goes
away
we disperse because we don't have
anything we don't have any glue that
keeps us together
and so we need community that keeps us
together the community unites around
those shared values
here's something that gets an important
distinction that gets left out of uh
a lot of the political shouting that we
do it's the distinction between a social
or moral philosophy
and a political philosophy your social
moral philosophy is
your set of beliefs about how societies
ought to function how human beings
should interact with one another and
live with each other
so if you say something like hey if you
see an old lady struggling to carry her
groceries she looks like she's gonna
fall over
i believe it would be a good thing for
you to help that lady out as long as
you're able to do so right
that's part of your social philosophy
now your political philosophy is your
set of beliefs about
the role that legislative force should
play in
implementing a particular social or
moral philosophy
so if you say something like i believe
government ought to pass a law
that says anyone who sees an old lady
struggling with their groceries
you gotta help her out or you're gonna
be fine or go to jail that's a political
philosophy
if you say i believe government should
stay out of that and we should make our
own decisions that too is a political
philosophy
and sometimes i think we assume that
just because people disagree with our
political philosophy
they don't share any common ground when
it comes to our social and moral
philosophy
and it locks us in this paradigm of
making us assume you're a bad person
you don't care about the poor you don't
care about those who struggle you don't
care about the elderly you don't care
about health care because you have a
different philosophy about the role that
government should play in it
and i think that's nonsense and it
hinders our ability to empathetically
communicate with one another
we have to begin from a starting point
that says hey look
we all have a common social and moral
philosophy we all want to create a
better world and we may have radically
different ideas about the role that
government should play in that
but let's at least talk to each other as
if we care
about our very existence as human beings
none of us all want to just fall over
and die
we just have different beliefs about
what's going to make us do that but why
do we unite against
people all the time we almost feel like
that because like
even if it's a toilet paper guy yeah or
if it is the president
or anyone else like we want to feel that
and by the way social media has made it
so that
that uh recreational outrage has become
a a
sort of uh pandemic and it's in its own
right
uh is that just because it feels like a
shortcut it's tribalism it's it's also
like i know but why
why the tribalism why tribalism instead
of community
uh it feels good to be angry i think
everyone wants to be a hero
and when you can go on social media and
you can start putting someone down in an
angry way and voicing this outrage you
some people actually feel like they're
doing some kind of good
but it feels good to help too so i don't
think it just because it feels good is
the answer why do we gravitate toward
that before we gravitate
so you said it anger is much easier to
to react on
than it is to react on empathy so
to tk's point like yeah it would be much
better for people to
uh uh to look at the mirror and be like
oh what can i go out how many old ladies
can i go and help today i'm gonna
keep a tally how many old ladies i can
help today where in
instead it's it's easier to get on
social media and to be outraged
and you you are getting the same exact
dopamine hit
whether you are expressing outrage or
whether you are going out and helping
old ladies and it's easier to express
the outrage that's my hypothesis on it
i agree with everything you just said i
would change one word from empathy to
compassion
um just because uh for those of you
who have read paul bloom's book the case
against empathy i
i i i believe in that sure i believe in
the case again yeah and you and i
disagree on stuff also sure yeah and all
i'm saying is that
uh especially in these times i don't
want people to be empathetic
and because what empathetic leads to
panic because what's happening now is
if i empathize with the guy who's
hoarding
toilet paper i'm also going to feel that
same panic that he feels i want to feel
compassion for him be like oh that poor
guy
yeah i can't believe he's panicking
there's a time and a place myself
there's a time and a place for empathy
certainly yeah i think another thing too
man is that
the right thing to do and this gets
downplayed a lot doing the right thing
is just kind of tough
you know why donuts over broccoli why
mcdonald's over trader joe's
it's it's just easier man it's so much
easier why
why why do we spend on stuff that isn't
important now
more than we save and invest like this
country is terrible when it comes to
investing and saving right
why is that because it's hard you know
it's not that no one's telling us to do
it prescriptively it's just it's it's
difficult to figure out how to do and
exercise the discipline so
the right things in life tend to be very
difficult in the short term
but very rewarding in the long term yeah
the things that are bad for us tend to
be
like that donut very delicious in the
short term but
not so rewarding in the long term and
that's just a difficult thing to do and
politics is no exception it's
it's easier to be lazy and to believe
what we're told
to believe what our family believes and
get our beliefs from our favorite news
network and from
whoever that charming political
commentator is than it is to do the hard
work of thinking for yourself
there are social costs that come from
thinking independently right there's a
lot of effort involved in doing your own
research
that can be tough it's just harder and
sometimes we do have to rely on proxies
and i think that's helpful i mean
i love following tk on twitter because
he's one of the proxies that i follow by
the way follow him at tk
at tk underscore coleman uh was there
another tk coleman somewhere
tkoman.comnot.gov
you know but anyway yeah tk is a proxy
for
many of these beliefs and i might but
even even then i don't want to
treat him as the proxy right and so i'll
have opposite proxies as well i might
follow someone like kyle kalinski who is
a progressive
and and really believes in and populism
and all of these other things and like
because i i don't agree with everything
that he says but i can
formulate my own opinion so you have to
have these different sort of
these proxies by which you do formulate
your own opinion right yeah
because we're not going to form any of
our opinions in a
or beliefs or ideas in a vacuum
there's the difference between personal
beliefs and memetic beliefs but most of
our beliefs i mean if you back me in the
corner i'm going to argue they're
probably the same thing they're all
mimetic beliefs because we are
influenced
by our community we're influenced by the
web
we are influenced by the articles we
read the books we read the tv shows we
watch and we're also influenced by all
the junk that we let in as well
those create those memetic beliefs just
as much if not more so
than the the uh the books that we read
yeah i think our problem
is humans want the shortest path
to dopamine hits and we take the easiest
paths like you
you said earlier josh like it is
unfortunately there's a lot of easy ways
to get those dopamine hits uh eating a
donut
being outraged on twitter that's so much
easier we're gonna get the same dopamine
head
as if we went out and went out and tried
to help old ladies but guess what
going out and hoping helping old ladies
takes self-regulation it takes
discipline it takes a lot of effort
and we uh yeah i mean it's it's
interesting i'm just like sitting here
thinking about how
our whole goal what we do with the
minimalists it's encouraging people to
make that effort
well let me let me let me finish this
this section here
because i think there's an interesting
conversation that you're both talking
about here
with the self-reliance but also the need
for some regulation
that ryan is talking about and i think
what what tk
is is saying is maybe that regulation is
is a bit overblown
at the very least but jordan represents
self-reliance be successful on your own
scale lebron represents like regulation
reps
help me out so that i can be so that
this is a fascinating analogy here
because
michael jordan
that's not right but i had to shoehorn
it that's pretty funny that's good that
was good all right all right
so uh article says here uh there are
many points where this
could have been avoided a better cdc
could have
made tests that worked from the
beginning or ramped up production
of working tests faster or they could
have come up with
smarter criteria for rationing tests
this is all true right
but it would have been even better to
have a system where things don't have to
go
perfectly and where a few mistakes don't
choke up
the entire response to an epidemic for
weeks
that is interesting because when things
don't go perfectly
it creates other negative consequences
all of a sudden we're going to sue the
government we're going to sue
oh man that's so interesting if we
hadn't let our culture
reach the point where governments ban
things by default
and review at leisure and where
individual and initiate
individual initiative is frowned upon in
favor of waiting for
official permission to do the right
thing
we could have recovered from all these
mistakes
hospitals would have used their existing
tests
which they already have more than enough
of doctors
would have had permission to test
suspicious cases
at their discretion that's the thing
that drives me the most crazy is
they have tests on site they are not
allowed to use
for the coronavirus unbelievable that's
regulation so what happens
what happens if they use it and they go
against the regulation i'm sure they get
shut down you can
you can't go against cdc and fda uh
if you are a hospital you would can you
imagine
trying to go against them um so anyway
uh
back to back to the text here to finish
this paragraph real quick
uh would have had the chant uh test
suspicious cases
at the discretion and we would have had
a chance to catch infections early
before they could spread that would have
been the key for containment
had we had enough tests had we tested
frequently
and aggressively had we created a
campaign of awareness not
panic we would have been able to get
more people tested and maybe
we could have contained the thing yeah
uh it seems that senegal may have
contained the the spread because they
did this
way before us and we could have done it
as well
had we gotten a lot of these roadblocks
out of the way
and we would have had the chance to
catch infections early if the government
didn't already regulate adrenaline
bisoprine insulin and
genetic testing to the point of
of near unavailability maybe people
would have thought
it was weirder or raised more of a fuss
when they started doing it for
coronavirus tests
too if you don't trust me trust former
fda director
scott gottleb who explains the situation
here
in an unusually candid communication
from an ex-government official
talking about his former agency his
twitter feed is a great resource
for information in general last sentence
here and here's a more careful analysis
of some of the laws around diagnostic
testing
and how they all contributed to the
current crisis
and by and by more careful i mean it
ends with
bottom line the fda is going to kill us
all
that seems like that that seems like
hyperbole to me
yeah but talk to me t.k like what do you
say it seems like
i mean because it almost seems like
they're projecting an intention and
we're not saying that it's the intention
of the fda
yeah to kill people we don't think that
right yeah yeah i agree with that
i i think most of the stupid and
incompetent and tragic things that we do
are based on good intentions which is
why the economist
thomas soul said that it's important
that whenever we evaluate
a policy we don't evaluate it according
to its intentions
but that we evaluate it according to its
actual outcomes right
and and this is where it can be very
easy to let smooth sayers
off the hook because many of the people
that do us the greatest harm
are people that actually want to help
right like man i just want to help the
poor
but just because you want to help the
poor doesn't mean you understand the
poor it doesn't mean you're competent
it doesn't mean you know economics it
doesn't mean that you know what's best
for those people
it just means you want to help but there
are people who want to help
who break things who screw things up and
who hurt people all the time
there's no reason to assume that
politicians are some kind of
magical exception to this fact and we
have to hold people accountable to not
just having great intentions not just
having a law for humanity
but devoting themselves to thinking
things through and
and evaluating the the policies that we
put in place to see if down the road
do they actually work i think that's so
important but ryan doesn't it make sense
for us to have some regular
it feels to me at least intrinsically
like some of these regulations
aren't just good intentioned but they do
save
lives no it seems that it makes sense to
me that that we need
some regulations yes but effective
regulations yeah there's a balance i
mean it's
think about the environmental
regulations if we didn't have clean air
acts and clean water acts
we would or you know deforestation uh
regulations
uh our environment would be much worse
off 100
i mean look at look at the the smog that
la had
uh back in what the 60s 70s or 60s and
70s yeah
70s was like actually 1990 was the peak
yeah
so like there was this cancerous cloud
in la that you couldn't avoid
and yeah it took the government to come
in and be like hey we have to regulate
this
otherwise uh citizens of los angeles are
going to die from cancer
uh because of this crazy smog they are
dying from cancer right absolutely yeah
so it's
so yeah i mean i i guess
i mean but you agree that there should
be some regulations right tk
it depends on what you mean by
regulation well so so
ryan's talking about right this is i
totally agree with ryan sam so in 1990
you look at the smog levels you look at
pictures from 1990 or 89 or 88
when when la was at its peak uh uh
cancerous cloud yeah yeah and and and
the regulations were put in place
have i have made it considerably better
however it's still the worst
city in in the country in terms of uh
pollution
but wouldn't you agree that those
regulations have made things better here
and that they were the best thing to do
yes so this is actually a very tough
argument that that anyone in my position
deals with
a lot both in in hypothetical futuristic
scenarios and when it comes to
historical examples
so let me just use an everyday example
to kind of illustrate
the the sort of struggle i have with
this argument let's say
uh you spill over your cup of coffee
okay
uh and i immediately see that it spilled
over and i go i gotta help josh
and i pick up the coffee i grab some
paper towel and i clean it up
is it true as a matter of fact that the
spill was cleaned up because of my
efforts
absolutely give credit where credit is
due i fixed it
i fixed the problem i cleaned up the
problem however
can we use that as a basis for arguing
that the problem would not have gotten
solved
had i not intervened well now that's a
little debatable
right because we don't get a chance to
see what that alternative outcome is
because tk intervened and cleaned it up
however
a case could be made that had tk not
intervened
there would have been other forces and
factors that would have been
incentivized
by their own self-interest to do
something about that particular problem
now i'm not even going to this is a
great example i had a roommate
who i left for a week and i came back
and he had spilled uh uh like a two
liter of coke
on the carpet and let it dry coca-cola
coca-cola
sitting there caked in sugary cake and
his
his uh because he wasn't regulated
because he wasn't regulated he didn't
clean it up because he is a lazy [ __ ]
he didn't clean it up right and his
thought was is well
we're moving because we're moving out in
the next month he really wasn't living
there he was living with his girlfriend
it's not my problem someone else would
clean it up so guess what uh
i didn't clean it up because i'm not
gonna sit there and i'm not gonna clean
his room for him
so uh the deposit paid for it and i just
kept the deposit and gave him none of
the deposit
when i got that check so uh there was
there was yes absolutely a mechanism
that came in to clean that up
but it cost there were so many
unnecessary resources
that were that were used up because he
didn't take initiative to clean up his
own mess
what is the economic term for this the
economic term when you do something
if you pollute and it negatively affects
other people there's an economic term
for this negative externalities yes
thank you
um and and so they're all the these
negative externalities of pollution
for example sure um you can
you can leave it off it's not a big deal
well what's funny is is uh
the the one of the the most common uses
of negative externalities actually
so so it means the unanticipated
negative consequences of a decision
and where we see negative externalities
play out the most
is with the regulation itself because
hardly anyone
is uh malicious enough to introduce
regulation
for the sake of screwing people over
even though that's what everyone from
the opposing political party
just assumes from default right most
people mean well and when they introduce
a regulation
they tend to think that this is going to
make the situation better
and negative externalities refer to the
the unseen consequences you have the
seen versus the unseen
i'm gonna do this to help the poor i'm
gonna do this to help the sick
and it's like oh no i didn't realize
that by putting that policy in place
i de-incentivized these people over here
who were doing all these good things and
now i just made everything worse
you have to think according to systems
this is why systems thinking is so
important
you can't just look at everything in
isolation so it's funny that we we talk
about negative externalities because
that's how it's often used
but you know um i i actually agree with
with ryan's example um
there are cases where someone could
someone could legitimately say you know
josh and everyone else in this room is
so lazy that that coffee would not have
gotten cleaned up unless tk
has done it but we should never assume
that it's always up for a debate we
shouldn't assume that it couldn't have
happened without me
and we shouldn't have assumed that
totally um you know that someone would
have would have fixed it
but here here's my philosophy on this
kind of stuff when it comes to
regulation or whatever it may be
i quote milton friedman here who said
that and i paraphrase them that
i'm not looking for a good man to run
the system
i'm looking for a system that is so good
that it incentivizes even the bad man
to do the right thing yeah and i think
that option
is always superior to the other option
right so so
should we have regulation well it
depends if
if the alternative is a system that can
incentivize
even the bad person to do the right
thing i'd rather have that
every single time than me depending on
something that requires
a good man to be in the position of
power to tell us what the rules are but
how do we do that i mean ryan's case
that he brings up about
los angeles is with all the smog and
everything else that's going on well
they didn't incentivize
bad people to do good things because
they were like basically basically like
hey if you don't do x y and z
that's not incentivizing that's
punishing i guess yeah yeah yeah that's
more that's more stick than
carrot mm-hmm yeah no but so your point
how would you incentivize your way out
of that if you if you were became earth
czar
what well first my first step would be
to immediately fire myself
or maybe pass a law that i cannot have
any successors
and there can no longer be any czars and
then i fire myself but i say we're all
in this together
let's figure out how to save our planet
right that'd be my first decision as
are i would use my authority to
pronounce authority to be meaningless
um but but um you know you know
i mean i have a seat over there she
wanted to hang out so
i told her she could sit right there
come on and hang out yep
yeah yeah no it's i think about the same
thing it's like how do you incentivize
people to
do community service like how do you go
out of your way to be
and i thought about that i was like how
in the world do you
uh like if i was earth czar i actually
had this thought experiment where it's
like how do you put something in place
how do you put a carrot in place
that makes people want to get up off the
couch and go out that old lady like
i don't know so so it's a it's a good
question tk do you have any idea how you
would
incentivize like the the smog example
for los angeles
so you know there are two aspects of
this like let me let me deal with the
community service thing there are two
aspects of this
one is is let's make sure
that we don't accept any unsubstantiated
claims
about the reality of voluntary community
service
right because it's easy to just kind of
grant someone the assumption
that if we didn't force people to do
community service human beings are just
so greedy that they would never do it
um if you're gonna make that claim
that's permissible but you have to
defend it just like any claims i would
make we shouldn't assume it
okay um and and i think this is very
important because
the statistics on this are very
surprising like human beings are
far more charitable um than we often
suppose but but so we we need to make
sure that all claims are defended well
let's defend that claim for a second
yeah because i mean because you bring up
a claim that uh most people are going to
be bad and they're not going to do
community service i would argue right
now
i said we shouldn't that shouldn't be
our default that could be true no
shouldn't be our default right but i'm
saying but but i'm saying that is the
default though unfortunately
like if you look at where the world is
right now with with all of the
pollution the plastic the uh
the damage that is happening to our
environment it is it is very
clear that people are not looking out
for the good of their community
they're looking out for the good of
themselves i mean that i feel like that
is the default i'm just kind of pushing
back a little bit and saying yes
i am assuming that is the default that
people are people are inherently good
when it's one-on-one but people are not
inherently constantly looking out for
their community and and having that
community service attitude
to the point where it does need to be
somehow it needs to be incentivized
i want to make sure i understand the
claim okay so you're saying you think
it's the default that
human nature is hardwired in such a way
that we are more likely to pursue our
own individual
gain um at the expense of what's good
for the communities around us
and unless there's some kind of
regulation that forces us to be
generous we won't are we seeing that
right now with the panic that's going on
at the stores
people are are acting only on they're
actually doing things that are hurting
other people because they're hoarding
these these toiletries or food or
whatever that
they're not going to use themselves they
suspect they're going to
so they are doing something that is
negatively affecting the other people in
their community as a result
and we still you're still skirting the
question about the la la smog
okay so so i i don't want to put myself
in the position of defending the claim
that human beings can't do bad things
that that there are not human beings out
there who will pursue their own
self-interest
at the expense of what's good for other
people there are people who will screw
you over
what i'm saying is if we're going to
make a generalized claim about human
beings as a whole
that we can't allow either one of those
positions to be the default
we can make particular claims i can say
yeah josh is the kind of dude
where all he cares about is money and if
he can step over your back and get it
he'll do it okay maybe that particular
claim is true but i can't extrapolate
from that and say
therefore my default assumption about
human nature itself
is that we as a whole are more likely to
do that
unless someone is forcing us to do the
opposite i i i i i think that's that at
least has to be defended yeah even
though i'm open open to it
i do i tell you no i totally understand
here's here's a more specific argument
to get back to this so
what makes charity possible the only
thing that can make charity possible
because resources have to come from
somewhere right
charity is driven by prosperity you
can't have charity without prosperity
and abundance in other words
you have to have human beings who have
more than enough to survive
yeah they have to feel that they have
enough yeah they have to feel like they
have enough to survive
and they have to be willing to share
from their state of
excess in order to help people who don't
have as much right
the number one driver of charity is not
government
the number one driver of charity is
private enterprise
more non-profits more charity
organizations
are financed by wealthy individuals
people that start business people that
accumulate excess worth
wealth through investing and so forth
and these people
through no law forcing them to do so out
of their own
greed out of their own self-interest
you know they choose to give money to
these philanthropic
organizations who then go out to serve
the world
we have before us a real argument of how
people not out of some desire
spiritual desire to make the world a
better place out of their own
self-interest
accumulate wealth and then circulate
that wealth in a way that helps other
people
out i wonder what the numbers are
because i think about like medicare
medicaid food stamps like i i just don't
know the numbers what what that is i
would say that
again don't know the numbers but i would
think that the what the government is
is giving out right now the social
programs the government has is more than
what
bill gates and every other
philanthropist is giving out every
single year
that's but i don't know the numbers i'm
bringing this up because i'm wondering
if you do know the number yeah
i have to be honest on that and and say
i don't but but like here's
here's just kind of like my problem with
this so
when when i said before that that
freedom is difficult right
that freedom is hard i i don't think
there is a
freedom does not promise that it gives
us solutions to all of our problems sure
right i don't think there's any way you
can set society up any kind of
government that you can have
that's going to liberate us from some
kind of situation where you say man
look at that screwed up thing that
happened over there what's the answer to
it
every political philosophy is going to
be forced at some point
to bow down to some kind of problem that
says
i don't have the answer right right like
screwed up things happen
regulation isn't going to do it either i
couldn't stop that serial killer
from killing 40 people before we caught
them governments
have failed in that regard and free
markets will fail in that regard right
but but kind of the challenge is
whenever you advocate for the free
market position
all we have to do is kind of find one
problem that that we don't
know the answer to and we say ah see we
need that regulation for that right but
on the regulation side
the system that we have right now we got
millions of people who are being
disenfranchised marginalized and ignored
and not looked out for
under these very systems slipping
through the cracks
and that never becomes an argument
against regulation
we just kind of assume oh well the free
market isn't helping those people we
need
more regulation we see it in education
and healthcare all the time
the push is always for more regulation
when people slip through the cracks
so the free market position is hard to
hold because
every single person that slips through
the cracks becomes an argument for
regulation
whereas the regulation position every
person who slips through the cracks
becomes an argument for more regulation
well i would posit that the article that
josh is
that we're bouncing off of here actually
does
give an example of this is why we need
to not have so much regulation
but i don't know if i don't know if
they're arguing that we need to not have
regulation they're just pointing out
that this there are some really bad
regulations right yeah yeah
i mean but my default would be whoever
wrote this that if you talk to them
about what should happen
they would probably blame it on a
particular politician and say we need a
new guy in office
that's how most people approach it most
people approach it from like to learn an
authoritarian perspective i need a new
czar because the current czar is not
benevolent enough yeah the people who
hate trump
are mad because it's not their guy and
then when their guy gets in the people
who oppose him are just going to be
like all we debate about is who gets to
make the rules for everyone else yeah
like like we don't have a problem with
power us making the rules for ourselves
yeah we don't have a problem with
authority we have a problem with
our particular authority being the one
who makes the rules it's interesting
because like
uh i'm just speaking of like you know
choosing sides and
this is my guy and this is your guy um i
try to keep like a very
open-minded approach and um i just want
to point out like because i really
feel bad that i feel like i've been
bashing like the trump administration
um yeah like i yeah that's not the
particular choice that i would make
you know going into the 2016 election
but i can also look at it and say hey
you know what like we're not at war with
iran
uh prescription drug prices are down
there were some really awesome like
regulations that were lifted
from from prescription drug prices like
there are a couple things i could be
like oh
okay like there is something good coming
out of this but all that to say
is i'm just really trying to help people
a
like not just plant their flag on one
side and stay there
but also you know have an open mind to
like yeah not just not just
becoming part of a tribe and bashing the
other side yeah yeah
i i i i did get accused of skirting
something and i oh and i want to bring
it i was gonna
i was gonna slide on it man no no i i
want to maintain my flawless record
across all mediums of never dodging a
question i will either be wrong
i will be forced to say i don't know but
i will never ever in the history of my
love
ever run from a question um so here's
what i would do if i were czar
and we're having problems with pollution
rather than just reacting to the
symptom i would do what a good czar
would do and i would diagnose the
problem
right i would say this is an energy
source
problem right um we have a whole bunch
of bad pollution that's making our
environment worse and we all agree with
that and why
because we're dependent on these
particular kinds of energy sources
so as the tsar let me unscrew up society
like the previous tsar did
by removing all of the artificial
restrictions on energy source innovation
that we have
and let's promote developing alternative
sources of energy
so that we can be able to fuel our
technologies and sustain our lives
without relying on an inferior quality
of energy
because every time we can improve the
quality of our energy source we can also
help
save our environment yeah no that's how
i would handle it i love that
um i think that uh if we started doing
that in the 50s and 60s it might be a
little bit different today but i feel
like
and maybe it's you know too early to
tell but the last decade
uh maybe even a little bit more than
that we have been incentivizing
other um sources of energy although
you're still getting fighting from other
side but but yeah i i like that answer
tika is what i'm really trying to say i
appreciate
that so i i just wanna i just wanna
highlight one aspect of what i would
uniquely do to incentivize it
um i wouldn't just be like yo tax cuts
and financial incentives for people that
want to innovate
i would also say hey all of you big
companies
no longer will you destroy the name of
capitalism by being in bed with
government
because so much of what we lay at the
feet of capitalism by criticizing big
business
is not capitalism at all in fact there's
a there's a pattern
of many entrepreneurs using a free
market understanding of economics to get
rich
and then the moment they get rich what
do they want to do they want to use
governments to artificially insulate
themselves from competition
right by putting in a bunch of quote
unquote consumer advocacy laws
that hinder the little guy from being
able to grow their business and compete
with them
because the big companies can afford to
pay the fees and the fines right
i had a melanie armstrong on my
revolution of one show and um
she was a hair braider she she
established the first hair braiding
salon in mississippi
and this is a woman who had customers
willing to pay her
she had the skill set to braid hair and
she had
everything right there to sort of create
her way
into wealth and guess what she couldn't
do it because there were these
consumer advocacy regulations in place
that required her to raise a whole bunch
of money
to be able to get the licenses that she
need to be able to do what she already
knew how to do
and what people were already willing to
pay her for and so she almost had to
go broke just to get out of being broke
and be able to create wealth
and this is the norm like
entrepreneurship creativity and
innovation
is nature's gift to humanity this is how
we lift ourselves out of
poverty nature is very unfair in that
she doesn't equally distribute talent
beauty
wealth and brilliance but nature always
gives us gifts
and as long as we don't have governments
artificially restricting our ability to
use our imagination
we have proven our capacity over and
over again to be badasses
human beings are badasses and i contend
that it is an
absolute lie to tell human beings
that you can't create your way out of
poverty you can you absolutely can
that's the message of hope no it's not
easy yes you need other people but when
we come together and work hard and use
our intelligence we can do amazing
beautiful things
and and so for me it's going back to my
czar thing
i would say to these other companies hey
you got here on your own you got to stay
here on your own
i'm going to stop protecting you from
the little guy so if you're supplying
these you know
pollution causing fuels i'm not going to
give you
incentives that allow you to
artificially insulate yourself from
these smaller businesses that are
innovating to compete and then we would
see more innovation because the
main stifle for innovation is
governments being involved with making
it harder for the little guy
to compete with the big guy and then we
blame it on capitalism it's corporatism
it's private interests and government
100 with one another crony capitalism as
well
crony capitalism yeah all right before
we wrap up i'm sorry man i just i
don't know i do want to talk about math
and respirators because this is
something that's come up
and where we're hearing conflicting sort
of news stories
um what have you heard about masks and
respirators and all these things uh i've
heard that people are hoarding masks
and they're trying to sell them at a
party good bad and different
what do you mean because they work for
oh oh oh like what should we do
uh i don't know what should we do are
they good are they bad like what should
we do as far as like using the masks uh
i have
i saw something the other day it didn't
give any evidence but it said if you
if you are not sick do not wear a mask
and i don't know if that's because they
want you to provide masks for people who
really need it
or if the masks actually somehow uh make
it easier for you to get the coronavirus
i don't know the answer to that but i've
heard that yeah if you're
not sick don't wear a mask same thing
with goggles it's like
yeah you might this is it's hard for me
to do this bad information you've been
given and that that's why i bring this
up and that's why i heard it
on that it's hard but i saw this on abc
news right now and
so let me let me just read from you so
people are coming down really hard
against face masks for coronavirus here
are three
articles wirecutter says this is these
are just the the titles and there's
links in here we'll put a link to this
whole article in the show notes here uh
this is the same blog post i've been
reading from the whole episode here
uh coming down really hard against face
mask for coronavirus wirecutter says you
don't need a face mask for coronavirus
marketwatch says u.s health officials
say americans
shouldn't wear face masks to prevent
coronavirus here are three other reasons
not to wear one fast company says five
reasons not to wear a surgical mask to
stop coronavirus
number five is quote just don't
as if that's a good reason the cdc and
department of health and human services
have both officially recommended against
mask wearing
some of the reasons given are idiotic
the virus is not common in the u.s yet
that was one of the reasons to not wear
a mask jesus
uh you so you were not so it's not
common so you were
wrong to worry uh this reminds me of all
the people saying
that artificial intelligence are not
currently super intelligent
so any discussion that ais might become
super intelligent
is just fear-mongering who are these
people how are they still alive
how do they avoid driving off cliffs
they're heading toward the cliff face
and their passengers
scream at them you're driving toward a
cliff
and they call me respond with we are not
falling off the cliff yet
we're on perfectly level ground there's
no reason to panic
other reasons are superficially better
but collapse under scrutiny
masks the article say only help people
who are sick
avoid transmitting the disease so
healthy people don't need to wear them
but the coronavirus can be asym
asymptomatic for weeks
so if you want contagious people
to if you want contagious people to wear
them part of your target demographic
will think that they are actually
healthy so if you become sick
you don't want to have to go out to the
store to buy a mask or wait for it to
arrive from amazon
you want to have it immediately other
reasons make more sense
standard issue surgical masks like the
one we wore on the plane a few weeks ago
to salt lake city
may not help as much especially if you
aren't trained how to use one
the coronavirus isn't airborne wearing a
mask while walking outside is
unnecessary wait the chronovirus is not
airborne
that's correct more bad information yeah
so we're getting this information so
you can catch it meaning if you sneeze
on me sure
you're projectiling the coronified but
if you're in this room you cough
and then you leave the room and then i
come in the coronal virus will be on
surfaces
that's correct but it's not hanging out
that is correct okay good to know and
there are several sources within this
article that show you the science behind
it so so
the so far here the argument for wearing
a mask is that you may be
asymptomatic and you will not pass it on
is there any evidence that says if you
wear a mask it'll prevent you from
getting the coronavirus yes and that's
where we're going with this all right
so uh the standard issue surgical mask
may not help as much because it's not
airborne wearing a mask
while walking outside is unnecessary
however if you're walking it's like
someone coughed in my direction
that will projectile towards you so you
have to
so it's not airborne meaning if he
coughs in the air and i walk through it
uh a a minute later or something it's
already hit the ground
or whatever surface that's nearby you
definitely want to be dodging at the
coffin in your face
for sure or or or a mask which we'll
talk about here
could help um going on going on and
other reasons
are really truly excellent if random
people buy up all the masks there won't
be enough left for healthcare workers or
they're very sick
yes that is the best point so if you
hoard masks
this is terrible for hospitals
healthcare workers who by the way we're
hearing horror stories right now
of people having to share masks in
hospitals
no can you imagine wow wouldn't that
increase your risk
if you have two unsick people but you
are afraid of of getting
the coronavis but to your point like
yeah it could yeah it could
it certainly would increase the risk yes
yeah um
uh but the thing is uh this is here's
the guy saying the thing is i already
own a p100 respirator
i bought it during fire season last year
aka the air is unbreathable season
living in california he's up up north
the uh
living california is full of excitement
and after a couple of
years you end up prepared for lots of
stuff the same thing was true and we
lived in in montana
and the other day i wore the p100
respirator on the bart
train in san francisco a densely packed
subway full of people
who were constantly breathing in your
face and my
friends told me haven't you heard that
the government says masks don't work
here's the thing an n rated p rated or r
rated respirators like the n95
respirators which you've seen
they have the little restaurant on the
front they're like a surgical mask but
they have the little respirator on the
front yes
those respirator masks if worn properly
in specific high-risk situations can be
an appropriate part of a safety strategy
i think an accurate treatment of the
topic would admit this
while also stressing the reasons most
masks
might not be appropriate for most
people in most situations the statements
and articles i've read don't seem to
have this level of subtlety instead they
seem focused on getting people to do
what they consider is the right thing
not horde masks and panic
at the cost of oversimplifying the
situation
sometimes up to the point of mistruth
and that's the thing that we have here
it goes on to
to talk more about mass we'll put a link
to this in the show notes but
here's the point to get here is most of
these things that we're talking about
have a degree of nuance it's not
binary it's not don't wear a mask or yes
definitely wear a mask
it's that hey maybe the surgical masks
don't help as much as we thought
but they will help you if you are
infected they'll help you
not spread it potentially but maybe an
n95 respirator
or a p100 respirator is
is a better solution if you can get one
the problem is people have been hoarding
them so they're virtually impossible to
get it's hard for me to believe that a
mask is somehow going to help you catch
the virus
more so if you didn't wear the mask like
that i don't understand unless you're
sharing them
right exactly yeah yeah so next week
we'll be talking about the economy and
we're going to talk about someone who
has been hoarding these things
and it's hard to outrage me but i am
i've been truly
outraged by by this guy and his brother
and
and we've been saving it up we have been
so uh that's it for this
maximal episode i would encourage you to
find tk
coleman over at tk coleman.com you can
follow me on twitter anywhere else we
should send folks
tk just remember dot com not not dot gov
no all right we love having you on the
show man i love having these
conversations it's it's important
i appreciate you guys so much thank you
for being here brother appreciate you
want to acknowledge what you're doing i
think you're doing something important
for the world i encourage people to
follow
your work and what you're doing love
people use things we'll see you next
time y'all
see ya be safe out there thanks peace